hi I'm Eric Voss and a head of
spider-man far from home director Jon
Watts revealed that one missing Easter
egg still remains undiscovered in the
previous film spider-man homecoming a
hidden reference to that malicious
Mallard Howard the Duck we here at new
rock stars and ever wants to turn down a
challenge which we have to assume this
was watts was totally cut the promo
calling us now brother and follow my
relentless searches for James Gunn's
missing Easter eggs and the guardians of
the galaxy movies and our beloved
investigation of the scroll impostor and
the MCU here join me as I rewatched fry
demand homecoming and reveal where
Howard the Duck is hiding in this
special Spidey Dustin has X Y T seconds
okay let's begin by reviewing Watts
words exactly it's like almost so
obscure that I don't even know if anyone
could ever find it but there's a Howard
the Duck reference it's a very small but
one thing to note is that Watts gives a
cautious look over to mr. Kevin Feige
after he reveals this and then when
other cast members like Gyllenhaal Tom
Holland ask where it is Watts goes
mysteriously silent Sam Jackson sat in
the front row teases always reasons to
go back probably while thinking about
that last time he tries to someone any
loss tonight and then the interviewer
suspiciously cuts off the interview what
the hell's going on is duck head just
got real it's also important to note
that Watts said the Easter Egg was a
reference to Howard the Duck as opposed
to Howard the Duck himself making a
whole cameo which makes this Easter Egg
a lot harder to find because you can't
just attune your eyes to white and
orange blurs also watts is more obsessed
than most Marvel directors when it comes
to literally in his movies with codes on
walls and services as Easter egg
references to comics a few of them have
already emerged in trailers for far from
home but when it comes to Home Coming I
got most of them in my first breakdown
of the movie two years ago go check that
out make fun of how baby-faced I was but
in this rewatch of homecoming here are
the new things I found so early in the
film when Peter is watching youtube
videos of himself during class this
video was uploaded by an account called
Brackett Robinson 67 and that's actually
a real YouTube channel that you can go
find it has a few spider-man homecoming
related videos on it one of them
the full version of the Midtown school
news hosted by Betty Brant Jason I and
ello with hilariously bad tim and eric'
style graphics and when you watch these
news segments in the movie there's a lot
of fun stuff like later one of the
screens behind Jason shows vision a nod
to a rival school in the New York area
Brooklyn vision Academy the high school
that miles morales goes to there's
actually a lot of nods in homecoming two
miles from the Ultimate Comics existing
in the MCU also this YouTube page is
recommended videos include a bunch from
a channel called Waverly flam's
which is the channel of director John
watts or film group from NYU Waverly
films in several of their old shorts are
featured on this page including floating
head lost in the city rainy day and bird
town which at first I thought could be
the Howard the Duck reference like a nod
to the duck world run of the comics but
it's not the reference and pretty sure
it's something else so let's move on
okay a few more new interesting details
emerge as Yuri watch like there's the
name Bagley and wall graffiti at one
point which are pretty sure is a nod to
Mark Bagley the comic book artist who
worked on a number of spider-man issues
there are also quite a few Asgard
references in spider-man homecoming
there's a Korean Church of Asgard and
the Asgardians comes up as a name of a
team that the Midtown Tigers play
against I mentioned in the new segment
video as well and later after Ironman
rescues Peter and takes them to a
playground to dry off there's one of
those spring writer things in the shape
of a duck it's hard to make out its face
but it could be Howard's
but that is still not the reference that
I found now others online have said that
Peters classmate Charles wears a Howard
the Duck shirt and the hotel is they
snake off the pool but after going
through that shot frame by Fleur can
frame a ton of times while the text font
in color looks similar to the Howard the
Duck cover titles Charles shirt I'm
pretty sure it says Road Trip now I
thought there was a good chance
something Howard related could have been
tucked into all the damage control
storage that litters this movie inside
the truck Peter gets trapped in there
are all kinds of odds and ends I thought
I saw something perhaps organic and
feathery looking at one point or maybe
what looked like some white feathers
poking out of a cage and another point
and I was just ready to give up but then
I remembered how detail obsessed John
watts is specifically about license
plates like in the far from home footage
we've seen so far there aren't license
plates that point to spider-man issue
numbers for Sandman molten man and hydro
man and I remembered how in homecoming
the plate of Aron Davis's car is UCS m01
which is a nod to Ultimate Comics
spider-man issue one the debut with
Miles Morales so I gave homecoming
another pass and yes the more details
start to show up in license plate
numbers when swinging around the suburbs
Peter briefly and moves the car covered
tarp over a plate but if you pause it
you can see it reads ASM 267 perhaps
four amazing spider-man issue 267 in
which spider-man has to chase down the
commuter to his hideout similar to the
chase Peter is in the middle of in this
sequence but even more references show
up on the ferry sequence in the middle
of the film one plate reads sm 205 6-3
which could be for spider-man issue 5
released in 1963 to spider-man's first
run-in with Doctor Doom but visible
another shot SM 1920 which could be for
spider-man issues 19 when spider-man
faces off against Sandman and issue 20
when he fights the scorpion which is one
of the characters he's fighting in the
same with Michael mando playing Mac
Gargan the scorpion seen from his neck
tattoo but if you turn a bit to the left
I think we found the nest folks a
license plate reads what looks like HT D
0 0 3 which I'm guessing refers to
Howard the Duck issue 3 in which Howard
watches a kung fu movie expresses
frustration and how movie violence has
got some kids to try to replicate it
which is the exact kind of caution that
Peter expresses in this fight scene
asking the arms dealers if he's being
too rough on them issue 3 is also when
Howard the Duck masters the martial art
of quack foo it's a very major step in
the character's life journey now I will
admit that the Howard the Duck Easter
egg that Watts is referring to might be
something else entirely so I want you
guys to rewatch homecoming and let me
know the results of your assets mighty
duck hunt and what do you make of what
suspicious tone around this reveal like
do you think Feige and Marvel Studios
have any secret plans in store for
Howard the Duck was his low cameo and
Avengers end game setting up something
greater comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at da vas and subscribe to new
rock stars for Marvel re watches and
of all kind for ducks for Scrolls for
rockets daddy and if you ask real nicely
for your daddy who went out for
cigarettes and never came back he's got
to be out there somewhere